Speaker 1: Kerry Lake has not been
mentioned on this show for a while,
but this is just too outrageous. Not to mention,
Kerry Lake now has a new story about what happened
in November. The news story is God told her that
she would lose her election in practical terms,
but she would still, quote, have the victory,
whatever that means. Kerry Lake did a church
prayer rally. It was completely ridiculous and
cartoonish. But here's what she had to say.
Speaker 3: I think I if you follow me,
you probably know that about a week or
two before the election, I had I was praying and
I just have heard the Holy Spirit is sealing it.
Speaker 1: And yet, don't you remember how
she told us that right before the election
she was in her room and the Holy Spirit was
inside of her Totally reasonable story, right?
Speaker 3: God, get me word that this
might not go the way you think it's.
Speaker 1: Going to go. Oh, really?
Speaker 3: I thought it was going to go
because of what I was seeing on the campaign trail
with the people of Arizona from all walks of life,
whether they're rural, whether they're a rancher,
whether they're a stay at home mom, a businessman,
a student, a youngster. We had come together in
this great movement because we want to have our
state go in great, prosperous, wonderful
direction. Right. So I figured with this
movement and what we've ever seen that was
led by God who used me with these skills,
I had to help lead it and get everyone together.
We were going to have a landslide victory,
which I will let you in on a secret. We did.
Speaker 4: There's really no.
Speaker 3: It all came to me in
prayer about a week and a half
before the elections and probably not going
to vote on what we think it's going to go.
The victory will still be yours, but it's
not going to go away and you can still go.
Speaker 1: So you're going
to lose in the earthly sense,
but you will have won in some other cosmic sense.
Speaker 3: And I just said to him, It's all for
you, whatever you want, whatever you need. And I
do believe with every fiber of my being, that we
needed to open more eyes and wake more people.
Speaker 1: Right. So listen, take your pick.
Is this a grift or is this mental illness?
Who's crazier? The person who says this or
the person who believes it? And I continue to be
shocked by the amount of time that God has for
American politics, Arizona politics, as well as
athletic events and everything. It's just it is
unbelievable the detail oriented nature of this
God. And so I as of course, everything she says
is incoherent. I guess now she's saying we did
win in a landslide, just not by the by the votes,
but you have the victory. And God told you this
a couple of weeks before, at some point. There
really needs to be a public conversation in the
United States about the toxic relationship with
religion that exists among the American right
wing. It's not that the right are the only ones
that are religious. But this particularly toxic
relationship where there are alleged religious
whatever are used in this particular way. It's one
of the most toxic things that I've said before.
I'm not saying Italy is perfect in any way,
but, you know, in Italy, Italy is a Catholic
country and I have lots of friends from Italy and
they all nominally identify as Catholic. They are
all horrified by this form of religion and its
interplay with civil government in the United
States. Because being Catholic in a place like
Italy for most people means something dramatically
different than when someone in the United States
on the American right says, I'm a Christian. We
are talking about very different things and this
is so toxic. But again, who's crazier Kerry Lake
for saying this stuff or the room full of people
that accepts it? You tell me. Make sure you
subscribe to our YouTube channel, which you can
find at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show.